[Musique]
nous sommes pas des exigences
qui sont les nôtres des objectifs que
nous nous sommes donnés à nous mêmes en
matière de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique devra matière de lutte pour
la biodiversité
[Musique]
mais depuis maintenant plusieurs années
on assiste partout dans le monde à une
véritable prise de conscience face à
l'urgence climatique
pourtant dans l'hexagone les mouvements
sociaux liés à l'environnement sont loin
d'être nouveau
guéthary en france l'un des cas les plus
récents est probablement l'un des plus
connus c'est bien sûr celui de la zad de
notre dame des landes près de nantes
qu'est ce que vous espérez en tirer on
est en plein milieu d'un endroit qui est
à garder
pourtant depuis maintenant plusieurs
années une autre lutte est menée sur
fond de protection de l'environnement et
de terre naturelle et ce à seulement
auprès d'une vingtaine de kilomètres du
périphérique parisien
et il a ainsi entre le premier en train
de se cristalliser parce que avec les la
prise de conscience pour le climat
actuellement chez les jeunes mais dans
l'ensemble de la population
on sait très bien que c'est ici et là si
les les bétonneurs commence à les
attaquer il y aura de plus en plus de
gens pour les défendre c'est vraiment
une zone à défendre cette zone à
défendre elle s'est dressée face au
projet de repas city un gigantesque
centre de commerces et de loisirs qui
devait être construit à gonesse dans le
val d'oise mais qui vient tout juste
d'être annulé le gouvernement a annoncé
l'abandon pur et simple du projet lors
du conseil de défense écologique
validant une information du journal le
monde
toutefois le débat fait rage car dans
ces territoires particulièrement touchés
par le chômage et la pauvreté
l'urgence climatique et la nécessité de
préserver l'environnement font parfois
face à une urgence sociale alarmante
qu'on a été abandonné mais ça fait des
années et des années qu'on a abandonné
alors qu'elle était véritablement ce
projet quelles transformations devait-il
apporter à la région et quels sont les
arguments qui alimente toujours ce débat
entre nécessité environnementale et
besoins sociaux pénétrer au coeur de la
bataille de repas city
[Applaudissements]
nous voici à gonesse dans le val d'oise
cette ville de plus de 26 mille
habitants est entouré par les aéroports
du bourget et de roissy charles de
gaulle parmi les voisines de cette
commune goussainville sarcelles villiers
le bel ou encore guerche les gonesse qui
souffraient en 2016 du sixième plus haut
taux de pauvreté de france avec 39 5% à
gonesse cette année là le taux de
pauvreté était de 24% alors que le taux
de chômage dépasser lui les 17%
c'est dans ce cadre et dans l'optique
notamment du grand paris que c'était
développer le projet du triangle de
gonesse
une vaste zone d'aménagement concerté
devant voir le jour en place d'un site
de 280 hectares de terres agricoles dont
la production annuelle s'estimerait à 25
mille tonnes de blé tendre
c'est au sein de cette zone que devait
être construit notamment un quartier
d'affaires comprenant par exemple 800
mille mètres carrés de bureaux et devant
générer près de 40000 emplois
une gare de métro de la ligne 10 est du
futur grand paris express
mais également un méga centre comprenant
entre autres deux cent trente mille
mètres carrés de commerces cent
cinquante mille mètres carrés d'espacés
de loisirs ou encore 2000 chambres
d'hôtel et devant créer plus de dix
mille emplois
ce centre financé par des
investissements de 3,1 milliards d'euros
de fonds privés
c'était europa city un projet qui
alimente depuis 2010 une rivalité
intense entre ses partisans et ses
opposants
[Musique]
on
2011le premier à seulement qu'on a fait
sur le client c'était 500 m d'ici
il y avait une centaine de personnes la
mode mais 2019
il y avait un millier de personnes la
marche qu'on a fait dernièrement à paris
on est arrivés vers matignon où il y
avait 1500 personnes
[Musique]
on organise qu'on appelle la nasa
dimanche et en fait c'est un petit
rassemblement pouvaient eux tous les
quinze jours et qui prend de plus en
plus en plus face aux mobilisations pour
l'environnement d'autres voix se sont
fait entendre comme celle du maire de
gonesse lui-même ou encore le collectif
des vrais gens regroupant des habitants
de la zone favorable au projet il faut
que ce soir à un projet qui soit aussi
utile seulement 1 mais ça chauffe les
stations vous pouvez voir aujourd'hui
dans les médias quand on entend parler
de notre de notre secteur c'est toujours
pour nous annoncer soit une émeute sur
un début d'émeute sur un crime soit un
meurtre
arrivé à un moment faut qu'on a besoin
de redorer l'image de notre territoire
au total ce sont près de 31 millions de
visiteurs qui étaient attendus chaque
année à europa city dont 6 millions de
touristes
et alors que la simple bétonisation des
terres naturels ou agricoles était déjà
contesté par les opposants au projet la
question de l'impact carbone d'une
infrastructure de cette échelle est elle
aussi dénoncé et ce malgré l'intégration
de contraintes environnementales à la
conception sa consommerait comme une
ville de 140 mille habitants moi je
plaide pour une approche équilibrée et
je crois que seule cette approche qui
devrait permettre consid urgence
écologique et urgences territoriale et
sociale
alors eux ils disent 01 pas que carbone
et autonomie énergétique
on a du mal à croire 0,1 point carbon
quand on prétend avoir 38 ans millions
de nos visiteurs c'est d'abord sur le
front juridique que c'est livrer cette
bataille
si bien que le projet qui devait être
livré en 2024 par citrus la filiale
immobilière de chant et wanda son
partenaire chinois fut finalement
retardé à 2027
et c'est bel et bien une annulation
n'être que le gouvernement a annoncé
jugeant que le projet était daté et
dépasser la lutte autour de repas city
c'est donc un véritable choc entre deux
réalités l'urgence climatique et
l'urgence sociale
un choc qui se conclut par une victoire
symbolique est particulièrement
importante pour les militants
écologistes
avec désormais le lancement de nouvelles
réflexions autour d'un projet alternatif
plus vaste que le triangle de gonesse
du côté des partisans de europa city
cette annonce est bien sûr
particulièrement sévère mais promet de
se heurter à une résistance importante
dans un communiqué le maire de gonesse a
déclaré qu emmanuel macron n'avait pas
compris l'avertissement de son peuple
par la voix et gilet jaune et qu'il
s'agissait d'une exécution en règle au
sans autre forme de procès au détriment
d'une population que le président
abandonne des propos déjà affirmé avant
même l'abandon du projet tant par l'élu
local que par les partisans du méga
centre et qui annonce d'ores et déjà que
la bataille de europa city pourrait bien
ne pas être terminée écoutez si mauvaise
nouvelle devait venir jusqu à preuve le
premier à sonner le top ça on retirait
encore un espoir à nos jeunes et
je peux vous dire que ça risque de faire
mal c'est à dire que la rassemblement
aujourd'hui très tranquille qui est
enjouée qui est sympathique ouais être
humain une colère et une colère du
territoire des habitants qui se
manifeste qu un quartier se paupériser
et plus la tension monte
on prêche la parole des habitants mais
arrivé à un moment quand ça chauffe ça
chauffe
je mets en garde aussi gouvernement sur
la tentation de sacrifier une urgence
territoriales en france et au liban on
peut par un trail tant d'années on ne
réalise pas ce territoire et nous dire
de ma vous étiez sacrifiés parce que
vous êtes un symbole
et comme on oublie que vous êtes un
territoires défavorisés auxquelles il
faut apporter des réponses c'est
incompréhensible